[Music]
this stage we wanted to kind of to bring
back some of the feeling of all the
fighting games like where you have
spectators in the background cheering
everyone on if there was nobody was
taking sides since the theme of this
overall is kind of Street Fighter 2
people have already found this like and
quoted it but like their intros are like
a Ryu and Ken intro which is why the the
background was gonna be that that we're
like if we're doing kind of like a
little love letter to fighting games or
to Street Fighter 2 we may as well make
the background feel like the 90s arcade
backgrounds were which not always Capcom
but this would almost be more SNK heavy
like King of Fighters like how every
background always had to have like 10
people cheering and then some of it is
just like classic we wanted that madness
that 30s feeling like the a couple with
the guy with his fork and the knife
staring at you like some people look
like they're cheering and then they look
like they're going to eat you
it's kind of beautiful so basically and
of course they're not 100% spot on but
basically every attack sort of
represents the Street Fighter 2
character so like rapid hands that rapid
hands is kind of like a Honda having
rapid hands also has the same kind of
foot stance the fireballs are all
obviously like a Ryu and Ken and then we
want to go loose so you're not 100% like
yes that's it but those are basically
yoga fireflies and then as the
transition to the next form we're like
how do you get Blanca in and we're like
just put a roll and then this part here
is just we tried to come up with
something that would use the same way
like a lariat would work like two
spinning arms and we knew the pattern we
wanted wind blowing so we're like why
not turn him into a fan
and very loosely that is sort of from
sonic booms so he has the same like
charge and then release and then so this
was to try to get the four bosses sort
of incorporated it matched the theme of
like being in kind of this weird
nightclub a place that you'd have a VLT
but sort of the boxer characters
represented by the gambling machine and
then it wasn't so easy it's not like the
patterns you play our match how the
characters are but you get tiger which
we just took from like tiger uppercut
and tiger shots from Seagal bison is the
American version of em bison so that's
what you get a tiger a bison and then
Vega or claw whatever you want to say
the snake tattoo on their body and it
didn't happen but we were gonna have the
first set of chips kind of have like a
little bit of a roll to them as they
come out the green ones just sort of
match like how he does his bounce roll
on the ground I think there's like three
or four more fighting game references
that haven't been found that people are
like this can't be all Street Fighter
and it's too loose to just say a role as
Blanca but I mean that's kind of how we
did everything in the game that's a
reference it's never going to be
distinctly them throwing an exact
Hadouken and sang Hadouken because
that's just we didn't need to be a game
like that we just wanted to pay a mosh
like a little love letter to all old
gaming and all animation by sneaking in
minor things I think this one because
fighting game communities are really
tight and pick up on stuff this got
picked up on the fastest
[Music]
you